[Music]
what is cloud identity it's a
cloud-based identity and access
management solution and device
management solution so you have two
solutions packaged into one single
product cloud identity right so it gives
you a single pane of glass for you to
manage all your users and devices and
also applications all from one single
pane of glass right and it also brings
beyond Corp security model to your
enterprises how many of you have heard
or know about beyond Corp security model
ok about 30 percent of the room so I
won't go very deep into beyond Corp
because it takes the entire session so
it's a but I wanted to give you a quick
one-minute intro on what be on car
because that's very important beyond
Corp is the next-generation security
model that Google conceived a few years
ago all right and there are key there
are two key tenets based on from a
beyond car security models perspective
the first one is no no trust network so
if you're not even trusting your own
network what we do is we inspect each
and every request that's coming to your
applications and we inspect make sure
that we these requests are authenticated
authorized and also encrypted right and
the second key thing from a beyond
corporate security model perspective is
we go beyond the traditional identity
based access right so we also look at
the context of the request where the
request is coming from what kind of
device you're using
are you using a company owned device or
BYOD device what kind of security
posture do you have on the device so
there are a lot of things that we look
at from a context perspective and then
you will be able to create these
granular access control permissions on
your application so that's the beyond
card right so cloud identity is the
vehicle that brings beyond karp security
model for your IT and business
applications
and also cloud identity is the identity
layer that powers G suite and g CP
applications it's been there for some
time right we have hundreds of thousands
of customers who are using cloud
identity about billions of users and
it's also offered as a standalone
product starting March of last year in
2018 and when you look at cloud identity
it it includes all the key components
that you normally look for in a in a
full-fledged Identity and Access
Management platform like user lifecycle
management account security multi-factor
authentication single sign-on into your
internal applications external
applications third-party SAS based
applications api s-- for extend ability
and reporting auditing for your
compliance purposes and most importantly
the open standards adherence rate so
sam'l Open ID Connect wot skin and
whatnot right and now you'll be asked
like hey what about some of the
on-premise applications that I have
right so we recognize that the SAS based
application adoption is going through
the roof for small business medium large
regardless of what's the size of your
business everyone is using SAS based
applications but like cinder said
yesterday in the keynote most of the
large companies they still have majority
of their applications and infrastructure
on-premise right for a variety of
reasons right so you may probably need
some more time to kind of migrate or
retire or modernize but what happens is
in this particular case giving your
employees a way to access these modern
applications and legacy applications in
a simple way it's really challenging and
it forces your IT teams to kind of like
start maintaining these two different
identity systems one for modern
applications one for on-premise
applications which increases your cost
and most importantly the complexity so
for those of you
who said we're using Active Directory
for your Active Directory admins you all
know how complex that could be great so
you have hundreds of servers probably
dozens of hundreds of servers depending
upon your company size and replication
to apology's trusts you need to set up
disaster recovery clustering so it's
complex right so as your company grows
the whole infrastructure becomes very
very complex so what's the deal right so
we have these two systems very costly
and then complex how to deal with that
issue that's where cloud identity hybrid
approach comes into picture right it
held it has the components that helps
you meet where you are we recognize you
have these on-premise applications and
probably you may need more time to
migrate and modernize those applications
or retire those applications or in some
cases you may want to continue to use it
for whatever reason right what we want
to do is we want to create that provide
the bridge to connect all those
on-premise based applications give a
versatile solution so that you can use
once in one single solution to use
integrate your SAS based applications
web applications and also on-premise
based applications what it does is it
basically helps you reduce the cost of
ownership and also most importantly
reducing the complexity that's
associated with on-premise enterprise
directories and then finally when you're
ready for example after some time when
you're ready to move some of your
applications and infrastructure and move
it to cloud maybe you're doing a lift
and shift the key thing is you don't
have to make any changes that are
related to identity so it'll be a
seamless transformation so one less
thing to worry about all right so now
let's zoom in to secure LDAP as I said
so this is one of the key component and
cloud identity hybrid approach what it
does is it's an LDAP as a service so
imagine you have a bunch of LDAP servers
in the cloud except you don't have to
set it up you don't have to manage it
you don't have to patch it it's all done
for you because it's a managed service
all right so what it does is it actually
your Google directory your users groups
everything and then it basically makes
it available as a giant LDAP directory
for your on-premise based applications
legacy applications that talk LDAP
protocol right and if your applications
are talking to an LDAP directory for
authentication authorization user
lookups group lookups no matter how you
use these LDAP applications so this can
be that LDAP application in the cloud
right and another key benefit is
regardless of where you have your
applications it could be on your
on-premise it could be in your private
cloud public cloud Amazon Google as your
doesn't matter so the access will be
very smooth okay now let's look at a
pictorial representation right so this
is a the most simplified version of an
on-premise infrastructure right so you
have some applications there you have IT
infrastructure like VPN servers or
radius servers network attached servers
and then printers and things like that
and also you have desktops so
traditionally they all connect to Active
Directory or one of your LDAP
directories like open LDAP so what you
can do is using secure LDAP you can go
to those applications and then there you
can onboard these applications into
cloud identity within minutes you'll be
able to see in a few minutes you onboard
those applications we generate digital
certificates for you and then you'll be
able to go to individual applications
upload the digital certificate go to the
directory settings and just point those
applications to secure LDAP as your LDAP
server and that's it and the most
important thing here is no user change
management required right so if they're
used to seeing the same kind of login
pages if you're if you're logging into
sa P your VPN solution so they'll be
seeing the same login pages so behind
the scenes instead of your servers
talking to an on-premise Active
Directory they'll be talking to secure
LDAP for authentication and directory
needs
so this is another scenario right so
traditionally when you lift and shift
some of those applications on to the
IaaS platforms right so you generally
throw in some VMs for Active Directory
because you want to support those
applications again it's not one or two
servers right so probably you will end
up setting up multiple VMs you need a
disaster recovery so you're throwing
more servers and if you're a large
company you have users in multiple
regions so now you copy and paste the
same setup in multiple regions and then
now if you have LDAP based applications
you might also need load balancers
before that so what you have done is the
complexity that you currently have on
premise with your directory servers you
just replicated the same kind of
complexity in the cloud it's a double
whammy in hell right so you have gob
cubed became even more complex so again
you can avoid all that by simply
integrating your cloud workloads
directly into secure LDAP so that you
don't need any of those active
directories out there however so we
recognize that there are some
applications that explicitly need Active
Directory for example if you have
Windows servers or maybe you have a
sequel server or SharePoint other
Microsoft applications so for those
reasons we've announced today something
called cloud ad which is a managed ad
service that you can use alright so in
summary the key benefits are you can use
one Identity and Access Management
system to integrate both your modern
applications and also legacy
applications and you can reduce the
dependence on on-premise directories
which will help you reduce the cost and
also the complexity and then finally it
gives you the Google scale Google
performance and also Google based
reliability when you use secure LDAP and
cloud identity secure LDAP is generally
available starting November of 2018 so
we have a lot of our customers who are
already reaping the
benefits of secure LDAP it's available
in cloud identity premium if you are a
GCP customer you start with the cloud
identity the base cloud identity all you
have to do is add on cloud identity
premium which allows you to use secure
LDAP and many other features that we
discussed previously single sign-on and
a bunch of other Identity and Access
Management features and if you're a G
suite customer if you if you have G
suite Enterprise all these capabilities
are part of G suite Enterprise if you're
using G suite basic or business you can
simply add on cloud identity premium on
top of what you have right and if you're
an education customer it's part of G
suite for education these are some of
the secure LDAP partners these are the
companies who work with us very closely
to integrate with secure LDAP and
papercut is one of those partners who
are in the room and these are not the
only applications that work with secure
LDAP right so they you can pick any LDAP
compliant application you'll be able to
integrate with secure LDAP all right so
let's switch to a quick demo in this
demo I'm going to show you how you can
onboard an application within cloud
identity and also how to point that
application to point to secure LDAP and
see how it works all right okay so for
those of you who are GCP customers our G
suite customers this is a familiar admin
console where you manage users groups
and applications and I'm clicking on
apps this is where you manage all your
applications single sign-on based
applications open ID connect these are
the LDAP based applications can be
managed here alright so this is the list
of applications that I currently have
and I click on add LDAP client in this
case integrating papercut
all right so in this screen you'll be
able to apply access control so you can
decide how much you want to expose your
directory to this LDAP client in this
particular case papercut right so for
example if papercut is used by only a
subset of people in your company all you
have to do is let me find this mouse
pointer here
alright I got my mask wander all right
so you click on selected organizational
units and you can decide which part of
your directory you want to expose right
and if you if this application is used
by your entire company and you may want
to expose your entire directory for
authentication and you can decide these
access controls not at the LDAP client
level but for each transaction right so
the first time first transaction is
verifying user credentials which is the
authentication part the next one is user
lookups same thing so if you want to
allow this application to do user
lookups for your entire directory you
click on entire domain and then you can
also decide whether you want to expose
your groups or not now I'm clicking on
add LDAP client within a few seconds we
will onboard this application and we're
also generating a digital certificate
that can be used and click on go to
counter the LDAP client details and
switching on this service
all right so once the application is
switched on its available to accept
requests from papercut so now the part
two of the configuration is you need to
go to paper cut and you point paper cut
to use Google as your LDAP directory
right so this is their admin console
here you'll be able to see a bunch of
LDAP directories select Google cloud
directory if you're configuring your own
LDAP applications don't worry if you
don't see Google cloud directory you can
pick any generic LDAP option there open
LDAP that should work fine and I've
typed in my domain name here and then
I'm uploading the digital certificate
and the digital certificate is uploaded
and clicking on synchronize now what's
happening is so now papercut is
authenticating with Google using this
digital certificate that we just
uploaded and once it authenticates it
was able to make calls and do user
lookups and group lookups using the LDAP
protocol and this is the admin use case
the other use case is the end user so
they can walk up to any multifunction
printer that are managed by papercut and
they can type in the Google credentials
they'll be able to release all this
print jobs so that's the end user use
case for papercut so if you've seen this
it took less than about five minutes for
us to come configure papercut or any
other applications all you need to do is
make sure you understand where to go and
where to punch in the details to point
to Google we have very detailed
documentation on how to configure all
the partner applications on our website
and we do have some generic
documentation if you have any other LDAP
application you want to configure any of
you ever flown on Air Asia no not you
Edward
okay so we're let's get to the day so
we're established in Malaysia in 2001 we
were actually Tony Fernandes bought an
airline for one Malaysian Ringgit which
was which is about 20 cents 25 cents it
got two planes and ten million dollars
of debt so since then we've put on
another 200 aircraft and we carry about
ninety to a hundred million passengers
this year we have 120 destinations or
more fly everywhere from Jeddah in Saudi
Arabia to to Hawaii and everywhere in
between and we have about 25,000 staff
and it's actually nine Airlines in five
different countries so Malaysia
Philippines India Thailand Indonesia
Japan for five or six okay so that's us
we are currently on active directory and
it's on prime active directory and it's
each country will have its own ad and
they all will all sing together
they're all supposed to sing together
but that's not necessarily how it works
it is extremely challenging to manage
and we really wouldn't be changing if
the auditors hadn't killed me every time
to do an audit and when they do IT
general controls audits they always find
people who exist in AD who had left a
company from the HR system said they
left X days ago there are there silly
aad are they are they they were removed
from ad days weeks months after they
left the company so that's a security
challenge and order challenge and it's
just too hard to manage
we have PowerShell scripts running
between between HR applications and AD
to pickup users configure them an ad
push him to multiple other systems that
they need access to
and it's it's by the grace of God if
that PowerShell script works doesn't
work fails fails at a particular record
HR may have give the person a different
email address in their in in the HR
system than we give them an ad it's it's
just too hard to manage why did we go
with cloud identity we didn't really go
with clarity we went with Google so
we're we are migrating all our apps onto
GCP and we currently have on Prem Cole
or private cloud SAS AWS as your Alibaba
we have applications everywhere that's
sounds like a very enlightened multi
cloud strategy but but it's not it's it
it has it has evolved that way and yeah
it's just it's too much to manage and we
have 215 odd applications that are
spread over all of those hosting methods
so yeah anybody else got similar
environment couple of hands went up
there yeah okay good yeah okay so not
only like when you saw it was reduced
dependency on ad we don't want to reduce
dependency we want to get rid of us
entirely out of our organization we want
to get off our enterprise license with
Microsoft we have got gmail G suite for
every single user we are pushing
everybody after chrome devices or even
contemplating turning Windows devices
into chrome devices and we'll have a
crack at never we're after this
conference I see a couple of guys from
the data team today boys so they're big
GCP users big data studio because they
love all the Google tools so we are
pushing the whole company so it's a
enterprise wide transformation to get
people off the Microsoft stack onto the
Google stack and we're in a hurry to get
there because our enterprise agreement
expires
next year so we want everything on GCP
everything I tend to get into cloud
identity every user using getting off
Microsoft Office products by by the end
of this year so that we're not at the
edge of a cliff when our enterprise
agreement expires let's see okay
actually I will go back and the one
biggest challenge there Microsoft Excel
that is absolutely the one challenge the
rest of moving clouds lift and shaved
building native on GCP that's that's all
quite easy using cloud identity and
spinning up applications and pointing in
my cloud identity that's easy enough
getting rid of ad that's actually not
too bad but getting people to give up
their Microsoft Excel is like is like we
have a team who all they do was go
around trying to kill Excel and they
make people cry they make grown adults
cry every week so so so don't try and do
that first leave that till last okay yes
a cloud native we want everything on GCP
because because we have too many clouds
and we have too much stuff spread all
over the place and we just want to
consolidate on one single cloud we are
not too worried about whether we need a
dual cloud for dr if the world google
loses the world there we will be in
trouble on that day but right now what
somebody digs up a piece of fiber
outside of our building we're in bigger
trouble
and these two are laughing because that
has happened last year yeah so so it's
not so much the cloud identity is a key
driver for our digital transformation
Google is and we we went with cloud
identity because it's your identity
product and not because we went through
an exhaustive search and decided it was
any soul searching decided what's best
for us it's your product we're pushing
everybody onto your products we're
pushing all our stuff onto your cloud
and we are working with Google to to
work through all the kinks to make it
work cost savings cost savings there is
is your Enterprise Agreement
right now we're carrying the Enterprise
Agreement for Microsoft and there your I
don't know what do you call the Google
licensing agreement but we're carrying
bought we will not say the penny until
we kill one of them and that one of them
is is the Enterprise Agreement okay
challenges I think all I've talked about
his challenges so far but again single
source of truth for we have a HR system
which true the magic of PowerShell
scripts tells tells us who joined and
who left and we push that true ad and
then use that to kill access in in all
of these downstream systems and it
doesn't really work it works most at a
time but if an auditor finds one guy in
an audit that said I failed they are the
IT general controls audit is a high
finding against me legacy apps we have
we have legacy going back to the day
Tony bought the airline because it's an
airline so you are always carrying
applications which are you have a legal
compliance to use an application which
works on a particular technology set and
if that vendor says I don't support then
he doesn't support and we have to keep
using the application so we need
something to fill in that gap paper cuz
I would rather we didn't use paper cut
by just killing all the printers but but
I'm not allowed do that so we do need
something to allow like we have a follow
me printing now and we need something
that allows that to work and paper cut
is is a good product and it does that
well but heads-up made I want to kill
the paper so once I get killing all of
this legacy Microsoft stuff will be
going after the paper but I think I've
been saying that for about 10 years and
in companies I've worked for and we
still have we still buy printers yeah ok
good
good okay that is the ultimate goal
so yeah ad it's it's like Rasputin you
keep putting bullets in it but we can
never actually kill it and it's a race
to kill it before it kills me and that's
that's why we need that's why we picked
we picked Kobol nothing well I hate this
sorry Google recording this but we did
not pick Google because we thought it
was the most mature and the best product
say it and the whole company Queens dat
me when I started making them use G
Drive and she's sweet and but we found
that Microsoft did not care about making
Active Directory that much better they
did not care about my general controls
audit findings they cared about selling
me their licenses or selling us their
licenses and Google that they will they
will come and say yeah you know what our
product is not that mature now we know
they know they're fighting against ad in
just 99% of all companies but they are
willing to fill in the gap between where
you're at now and even we will give them
systems where we don't have any
documentation we don't know what the
system does and sometimes we don't even
know where it's hosted but we just give
it to Google give it to their partners
and Edward there is he's just knocking
over those systems one at a time
I mean have we done so far Edward 20
years off more yeah so we're we're maybe
20% maybe a quarter of the way true
where we need to be and we have to get
there by the end of this year this is
our environment Edward this is the
cleanest version of our environments
that I have ever seen Wow put a little
bit on that yeah a little bit yeah if
you look like this we don't need you
guys
we'll stick with it a little sick but
Eddie
but yeah it's it's a hell of a lot
messier than that and and there's lots
of there's even applications in there
which we don't go true
we just go here login totally we we have
a single sign-on system that we cost and
built many many years before my time and
and sometimes it talks to ad sometimes a
dozen some systems are just too old
schools that we just say here user go
and figure out how to login manage to
passwords we don't care if it never
expires just work it out but that's an
Isis diagram I ever seen of our
environment
and in many cases what we see is it's
even hard to kind of like know how many
applications you have so when we talk to
our customers like hey tell us like how
many applications are talking to 80
they'll say good luck so I'll come back
after three months right so because
there's no application inventory
management and things like that so you
have these applications floating around
in spreadsheets all over and then you
have these spreadsheets with application
owners and their individual admins and
the boys over there I'll tell you we
restructure every six months and
companies departments come and go they
go off and be their own companies and
then they come back into the group and
then they go back out again and we're
having to change the main names for
let's say we spun off our ground
handling company into a separate company
in a JV with a Singapore ground handler
so overnight 5,000 staff work for a
different company they still need to
authenticate back into our applications
because they're doing the ground
handling for us they they had at AirAsia
comm email addresses at midnight one
night and then at 12:01 they became at
GTR comm they still have all our
hardware they still have all our they're
still doing work for us is still wearing
shirts with the areas your logo on it
but they're a separate company separate
HR system separate payroll separate
policies and we have to manage that
happening quite a lot and we have that's
happened over the last 10 years or when
people leave those other companies we
don't always know about it so we're
relying on and so sometimes it's even
the
HR person has to send an Excel
spreadsheet awastha we have to download
and you give that to an auditor it's
like shooting fish in a barrel so we
have a nice diagram I wish you she was
like this okay this is getting more like
it now okay so we're gonna kill all of
that and that's what CRM system is is
Salesforce HR system is is workday so
Salesforce no problem workday problem
now but soon to be not a problem because
we're working hard we find we spend a
lot of time bullying the third-party
vendors to to talk to Google Google are
very good at saying ok we'll do it
please try and make your vendor do it so
work they are one of those vendors so
technology is ready its contractual
we're waiting for contractual issues to
be resolved before we can just hook a
true cloud identity and we find that
with the with the smaller vendors we're
we're the biggest client it's ok we can
bully them but for the big guys yeah we
kind of need Google and and having
Google as a partner who are willing to
to do that for us that works really well
for us ok App Engine so the dev team are
happily building stuff on App Engine so
that stuff gets hooked in fairly
natively VPNs again yeah this stuff is
fairly standard
we are moving everybody off those
windows environmental again on desktops
we are pushing people onto Chromebooks
again more people are crying but we just
bribe them with pixel books and then and
and they like it but but once that
Microsoft Enterprise Agreement goes all
of those windows licenses for those
people to sign into those machines will
disappear so we will need some way for
we will need an emulator to allow Wintel
tech at the backend hosted on GCP to
talk to a user we will use we will use
SAS pass and Citrix we will have RDS
licenses which are will still need that
RDS pista to talk to that back in Wintel
we will either just
consume that license from Microsoft
ourselves or we will build it into
situations S Class
and we will use SAS pass as well to do
to do the single sign-on and the
password management piece and eventually
we will we have to pick Citrix because
of one legacy our one of our most
important application it's it's too
important for us to do it while trying
to make it work on south pass so we need
Citrix for that a little bit of
complexity but not too bad
ok benefits so yeah we're going
everything on GCP absolutely everything
the one caveat is China so 20% of our
revenue come our passengers and revenue
comes out of China I won't ask any
Google people to comment on on their on
their China strategy here but our issue
is more bad bad actors in China coming
at us and trying to hold inventory on
our website so anybody else here work
for an airline no well the the problem
for us is that in order for us to sell
you a seat on the airline we have to
make sure we hold that inventory before
you give us the money and because that
inventory is finite there's only 180
seats on an a320 a a bot will come along
hold that inventory pass us a fake
payment hold that seat for as long as
the bank comes back and tells the
payment is refused so that might be
seconds might be minutes we will wait up
to 15 minutes for the bank to respond
and they will hit a plane one flight
tens of thousands of times dominating
all of that inventory and not allowing a
real person to to actually buy the seat
they will take that inventory advertise
it on on a third-party website like an
OTA site in China so if they if they're
holding it at a hundred bucks
they will advertise it at a hundred and
fifty bucks they will wait til somebody
gives them a hundred and fifty bucks
then they will give us a hundred and
then four hours before the flight
departs they will drop any inventory
that they haven't held because they
can't sell we can't we have to legally
stop selling for
before the flight departs so so we may
and we've been having this problem for
two years maybe longer
so - longer we're a flight we'll look
like it's got no seats left we could
look the law look sold or held but it
will take off with the flight half empty
and that's a massive hit on our revenue
and those bad guys are coming from
inside China so we need a wife inside
China they can see the traffic right
from the origin so until Google get
their Armour product to be a real AI
driven wife tool not just a IP blacklist
then then yeah we'll we're we're stuck
on Alibaba he's a management I think you
have described how how we currently
manage to ad and that's not very easy so
we want that single pane of glass single
console everything managed to it and we
want gooeys like that I don't want to be
having to dive down into into physical
ad boxes in five different countries to
see why a profile exists in one place
that supposed to be gone and that's just
a nightmare now security concerns yeah
the security concerns are because we
keep having these IT general controls
issues all of those people are the if
they if they're in AD they're inside the
network if they're inside the network
they have access to data and systems and
if they are bad actors and true true or
mission by us they have access then our
data is insecure we cannot have that
happen in this day and age so that needs
to be fixed this year and cost-saving
simple just kill that enterprise
agreement
[Music]